on a demandé un autre panel
municipal de revenir sur ce sujet là
c'est quand même ça arrive pas tous les
jours elle me sens bonsoir bonsoir
tout
de suite
tous les jours tous les jours tous les
jours
est-ce que dans le fond moi je pense que
c'est
une grande force
tatoué sur le cœur mais il faut que nous
convaincre il faut que tu me convaincre
que c'est tout Montréal-Nord tous les
citoyens et que tous les ans je l'ai qui
voyait que tu vas avoir la confiance à
police qui va avoir la confiance dans
les relations opérationnel au quotidien
donc vous dit je vous êtes elle aurait
dû partir malgré le bon coup qu'elle a
eu d'aller le chercher
où elle
travaille
avec les jeunes
avec des jeunes
actuellement où le bât blesse c'est
qu'effectivement
lorsqu'il a eu son erreur on peut pas
calculé seule comme une erreur de
jeunesse qui était policier à la GRC
avait quand même 27 ans responsable de
ses actes sachant qu'il y avait pas le
droit de le faire et il le fait pour
contacter de ses amis proches qui était
dans les gagnants de russe pour demain
comme vous l'avez dit dans une enquête
de meurtre et ça c'est quand même assez
troublant parce que demain matin il me
supporte pas arrêté du maire de
l'arrondissement en C-4 seulement avec
tous les problèmes que nous avons à
Montréal et les gagne 2 rue qu'elles
vont être son autorité a discuté avec le
directeur de son poste de police de
quartier sur les stratégie à adopter
pour l'instant les policiers en aucune
confiance malheureusement il aurait pu
être infirmier y aurait pu être médecin
il y aurait pu être docteur il y aurait
plus à toutes sortes de choses sauf
politicien si aujourd'hui on sera pas là
pour en parler parce que c'est le repos
d'influence sur sa cape de prendre des
décisions c'est un point intéressant que
vous soulevez sa relation s'il était lui
futur avec les les forces policière en
même temps même si on est convaincu tu
feras s'il est élu un bon travail est-ce
que la fonte même si c'est il y a 22 ans
et Portel que aujourd'hui dans le
contexte de sécuritaire ou un peu
d'angoisse à Montréal le fais pas le
choix de me dire au revoir oui parce que
parce que en fait ils sont
tous ceux qui
ont été élevés
tout seul c'est son bagage et si se
débarrasser de ce magasin qui est un
bagage rare en politique c'est très très
rare que quelqu'un se présente comme
mère avec ce bagages avec cette passion
de régler des problèmes il y a dit qu'il
voulait aller chercher des centaines de
millions dans la pour le retard
et j'y crois je crois que s'il y a
quelqu'un qui serait capable de ça
serait lui
il
est
là
avoir justement ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est de me faire de la
publicité parce que ces jeunes qui ont
peut-être jamais été votée bon peut-être
se mobiliser davantage pour nous on a
une chance de faire les roues et le prof
pas et on va aller voir si tu fais pas
partie de notre 42 % de taux de
participation de votre c'est peut-être
je voudrais qu'un contenu des
circonstances malgré les qualités que il
peut avoir dans dans dans dans Montréal
Nord actuellement avec la situation de
rue la confiance ne répond et Hello
parce que avec nos policiers on aurait
pas pu régler le problème
votre même si je t'aime votre un gros
câlin